who's Randy don't bring anyone love into
this no more motherfucker said hello dad
hey buddy how you doing good it's been a
while yeah how long it's been
well I'm doing good you know I'm just
working half-day is nice that's nice you
know hey it is you know one of my
buddies has a funny reference I don't
know if you've heard this before but he
calls his wife's boobs
state troopers called her what he calls
her boobs
state troopers oh my god I can't believe
oh not what I call a loving comment yeah
god state pretty funny I play trooper
women you know they got to where they
don't make bulletproof vests from my
books
do they not know what do I didn't know
of I mean are you well hidden in the
bulletproof vest market I asked one of
us I asked one of my you know my
secretary is uh-huh seems a cop
yeah okay and rested they have a special
model for women and she says I don't
think so oh all right
very well-written oh my weight accurate
yeah yeah so there's been a lot of
excitement anticipation about what's
going to happen with fart mistress calm
the website that I bought and yeah and
and whether or not mom is going to fart
on it and you know at first I was going
to try to raise money but now I think
what I'm going to do is just pay her
myself but she was saying that she felt
like a prostitute but I mean she don't
to get naked or anything he's just fart
what's the big deal
you know I really don't understand I
mean the other day I did I tell you
about that that shit I did the other day
huh
god no no no all right so I'm on a I'm
on a road trip up there seeing Jane and
what always happens when you go on a
road trip if you get up for the more you
hit the road and I'm on the highway yeah
and if I do that you know my 815 bombs
away
time is doesn't happen so I went a whole
day without a single shit Oh No yeah
that's really bad well I knew it was
going to happen the next day I know it's
going to be ugly
so woke up you know I'm home back to my
normal routine kind of did a kind of a
you know kind of a smaller one probably
cuz no it couldn't win that big and then
and drive into the gate via where we
live and all of a sudden I feel it
coming and I know that feeling I said oh
my god am I going to make it so you were
on your way in or out on the way into
the subdivision okay yeah so you know
heading down there and then you know you
know that feeling when you have to go
you have to kind of squeeze your cheeks
together you have to stretch your legs
out yeah how far are you from the house
as you're feeling this
oh I'm you know quarter mile okay I make
that liyan left-hand turn down our
street pulling the driveway but then I
got to get out of the car you know that
I got to keep my teeth together as I'm
getting out of the car and the whole
idea is you know to try to run in there
and hand make that right turn and when I
made that right turn you know some of it
just slipped out what and what some of
the shit King came out and I when I got
there on the toilet oh yeah you know it
was really messy you know
I had I had some in fact it was so messy
that I had to wipe I don't normally do
this but I had some of my left cheek I
had to you know wipe my left cheek with
my left hand I mean I had you know yeah
that's it that's it unorthodox it feels
different right to use your other thing
well it does it's very unorthodox and
then then I look down at my underwear
and I can see some shit basically I had
a few you know niblets in my underwear
and then I left inside my trousers and
some of it fell into inside my trousers
so do you throw that stuff away what do
you do with that oh no and I just rinse
it rinse it off in the laundry we just
rent it often this is like so Canada
yeah that's where why don't you why
would you just throw the underwear out
well why so it's perfectly good
underwear
19:19 or it's not the cover - because
it's got it listen listen I I know a lot
about you know sunset in your pants kind
of stuff and thanks a lot more that to
ruin a good pair of underwear what is it
I mean what would it take to ruin a good
pair of underwear mostly one the elastic
gets worn out I mean so if you had like
a full if you got a full shit in your
pants you still keep them yeah I mean I
died what I do is to take the shit put
it in the toilet uh read the rest of it
in there and it's all looking then it's
in that B and then you know you just
recycle so listen tell me all these
nasty little trope go down to where away
then but it's not identity not good
anymore that's the whole point
well it is good once once you put in
washing machine and hot water and soap
it comes out nice and white or blue
whatever color - what alright now and
another episode no you should just try
say it what I would be issue here really
for me was I have to when I really got
to go I got to work on making those
turns and
bathroom you got to work on that yeah
because I made that turn and of course
it means you put your legs and when you
make that turn
that's one my ways the wasa time what
turn are you talking about though going
from in the house to the bathroom so
through the laundry room you have the
laundry room then I gotta turn rights
closest bathroom you know is just
bathroom you jump in the shower after
that oh yeah of course yeah after yeah
after yeah yeah it was I had to it was
such a mess I had jump in the shower and
[Music]
sleep hey oh my god what's up with the
I'm just changing the topic cuz I'm
about to puke in my mouth but what do
you are you into those new bra new bras
mom got but are you still digging those
or you not I mean you're not liking
those anymore well I'm a lace man okay
yeah I was like you I always like to see
through you know give a little little
you know see you there see that nipples
and other things I've always been a lace
guy and you know these functional lift
bras with you know if there had been my
my favorites but again I'm not going to
tell her that is she wearing them what
is she wearing now the functional ones
oh yes you she's awful so not well why
don't you just get her some lace ones
yeah just you'll wear but she doesn't is
she did but she likes the functional um
yeah yeah so I was telling uh I was
telling Christina Outfitters about this
girl I went out with in college once who
she had such a full Bush that it looked
like she had a pair of balls when she
when she had her panties on it was like
too much well you know my generation it
was all about the bush okay
no it's I mean my generation the girls
never shaved okay just just to do that
and you would classify women by
nationality whether they had big Bush or
low Bush oh really oh yeah yes we're
basically you're Italians you're Greeks
yeah you know Jewish red black black
bushes
or Scandinavians you're you know late
though Asians the head you know very
little right and with and and and the
Irish to death in English you never know
what you're going to get with that I
mean it was all over the map but the big
ones right there the big the big black
bushes where the you know that kind of
lower European Mediterranean right in
the year well that's what this girl was
she was Portuguese yeah yeah I can
imagine I mean I saw those panties and I
go I'm about to hook up with a guy right
now well I tell you some of those girls
in those days they did partial shades
because you know that they would it
would almost be like a reverse triangle
you know would counter the hair would
kind of go up towards enables the girls
would which shave themself partially
know like from below the navel because
we can't we grow up so high oh yeah you
couldn't wear a bikini otherwise oh I
see yeah yeah that's very common in our
generation yeah yeah this girl had a lot
of hair a small penis but a lot of hair
she had a small penis but a lot of hair
that's good that's good yeah I'm so
thrilled yeah thank you i yeah but I
haven't had an accident like that Tommy
in a long time uh I feel like I feel
like it's happened a few times in the
last year though I feel like it's not
that yeah it's all it's all do you know
it's all due to when I travel on the car
what happens is you know when you get up
you're you're not in your routine you
eat differently in the morning yeah
coffee
you know you're on the road and then for
some reason it just stays there in your
rectum or I know I have a lot of travel
day problems you know travel day
especially I don't know how you do it
quite frankly
[Music]